[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHEN ELLIOTT: All right.
Thanks, everyone, for coming
to I/O 103, Monitoring
and Forecasting Your GCP Costs.
I'm Stephen Elliott.
I'm a product manager
on Google Cloud Billing.
And my colleague
here, Phill Coletti--
that's Phill with two Ls--
and he's also a product manager
on Google Cloud Billing.
And we're really excited
here to talk to you
about cost management
in the cloud
and on Google Cloud
Platform in particular.
But just to get
started, I just want
to get a quick show of hands
and get a sense of who's
in the audience.
How many of you use any
cloud provider today?
OK, so vast majority.
How many of you are on
Google Cloud Platform today?
And then maybe the flip
side, how many of you
are evaluating, but not
on Google Cloud yet?
Great.
And then, rough
sense, how many of you
feel like you are really good
at managing and monitoring
cloud provider costs?
A third.
And how many of you feel like
you need to learn something,
or need some help or
tools to help with it?
OK, great, got it.
So before we dive into the meat
of how cost reporting works
on Google Cloud, I want to
do a little introductory trip
into cost management
in the cloud
with a company you've probably
heard of before, Waze.
If you live in the Bay
Area, you might have even
used Waze to get here.
Waze was founded in 2008.
It was called FreeMap
Israel, I believe.
And it was acquired
by Google in 2013.
So now it's a Google company.
And obviously, they run part of
their infrastructure on Google
Cloud Platform,
or else I wouldn't
be including them in this talk.
One of the things they do,
which you are familiar with,
is their traffic application.
They help you navigate and
get to where you need to go.
They find the best
route for you based
on help from other drivers.
And this is actually
a map of where
Phill and I work in Seattle.
And it's showing you three
routes from Downtown Seattle
to Fremont.
Now, two of the routes,
I don't recommend.
But the fastest route
does seem like the route
I would take to get from the
Hilton downtown to Fremont.
And right where that
Google Cloud logo is
is Google in Fremont.
And you can kind of see
what Waze is doing here.
It has traffic notifications
based on drivers.
So this is all coming
in from drivers' apps.
There's heavy traffic
on the 520 bridge.
There's basically heavy
traffic everywhere in Seattle
this morning at 9:00 AM.
That's pretty standard.
There's also other events,
like these pink barricades
that are showing where
drivers are reporting roads
are shut down.
There's a policeman,
apparently, in Interbay.
And there's construction
workers downtown.
So the important
thing about this
is, Waze is doing
this, as you know,
all over the world
for millions of users.
They're in 185 countries.
And they have 500,000
maps contributors.
And we all know that route
navigation and route finding
is already a computationally
hard problem.
And Waze is doing a lot
more than just that.
So it's doing this
for millions of users
around the world in real time.
It's also doing
anomaly detection.
It's reporting what it
thinks might be safety
incidents to local authorities.
It's doing sentiment
analysis on users
to make sure that their
experience on the Waze app
is good.
It's taking all of those
map contributions in.
And it's doing this
in every major city.
And you can kind of see--
what I love about this video,
and you can see a series
of these on YouTube,
is how Waze is
living and breathing
as it's serving its customers.
And in particular, all of
its services on this chart,
and on this slide and elsewhere,
are spinning up and spinning
down with Waze customer demand.
So in the morning, when
Waze customers are driving,
Waze is spinning up
more compute resources.
There's more BigQuery activity.
There's more big data
activity-- storage and database,
management, networking activity.
And actually, in a chart
later on in this presentation,
you'll see what's happening.
And this a really cool aspect
of all of these services
and of being in the
cloud, is that they're all
available on demand.
And they literally
breathe in and out
with the demand on
the infrastructure.
So that's something I just
want to talk about and frame
this talk a little
bit before we dive
into the cost reporting tools.
It is one of the
things you probably
hear a lot about moving onto the
cloud from a legacy provider,
or operating on various
cloud providers,
is the ability to trade
capital expenditures
for operational expenditures.
So here's just an illustrative
oversimplification-- cost
on the y-axis and
time on the x-axis.
And this might be a
hypothetical application,
and you're forecasting the
demand that application will
have on your infrastructure.
And in the
traditional world, you
would have to make
sure you plan ahead,
and buy that
infrastructure, and procure
the hardware in advance.
And this timeline could be
anywhere between days to weeks.
And usually, it's
more like months--
three months to six months to
get the data center in place,
to get the capacity you need
to run a new application,
to launch in a new region,
to launch your business
internationally,
to serve international
customers.
Now, in the worst-case
scenario, you get it wrong.
And your demand exceeds
what you planned for.
And this either results in
unserved demand or unhappy
customers.
And so that's usually why I try
to over-provision to make sure
you don't hit that.
And then it's a balancing
act, because you
don't want to
over-provision too much,
because in the
best-case scenario,
you have unused capacity.
So the obvious immediate
benefit of moving
from capital expenditures
to operational expenditures
is, this unused capacity
becomes unused capacity savings.
So that's capacity you
didn't have to use,
you didn't have to spin up.
And all of those services
on the Google Cloud Platform
slide that Waze uses don't
incur costs for Waze.
But there's another value that
I want you to think hard about--
and sometimes, this gets lost
in some discussions about cost
monitoring and
cost forecasting--
is the ability to
meet surprise demand.
So this could be, very
simply, a social media app
in the early 2000s
scales really fast
and shuts down because it
wasn't able to meet demand
in its data centers.
Or you're delivering
traffic more slowly,
and it's just a bad
customer experience.
But another way
to think about it
is also, what are the projects
that your company's not
doing because your
employees are stymied?
They realize it's
going to take three
months to get a project off the
ground, to even run a pilot.
And so they don't bother asking.
We all work in
knowledge economies.
We have very important
employees who
might be the most valuable thing
that we have in our companies.
And whenever we slow down the
work that they want to do,
that has really drastic
implications for our business.
So one of my colleagues,
Matt Leonard,
gave a talk with Lucas Carlson
at the Broad Institute.
And the Broad was the first
to sequence the human genome.
And if I recall
correctly, they've
sequenced 100,000
since they started.
And you can imagine,
if there's any delay,
if there's a significant delay
when researchers can actually
get results, that impacts not
just the Broad, but actually--
I know this is kind of
over-emphasizing, but mankind.
The time to science
is very long.
So some key questions I just
want to put in your head,
and you can ask
yourself these questions
as you go through the demo
with Phill, are these three.
So how much does my app cost?
What are my cost trends?
And what are the
drivers of those trends?
And what I like about
these questions is,
they're kind of fractal.
They apply to any level
of the organization.
And you'll find that your CIO
or CTO is asking the question.
And you'll also find that the
developer actually creating
the application or
operating the application
needs to be able to answer
these questions as well
in very fine detail.
So we can give you at-a-glance
answers to all three
of these questions, even for
one of our biggest customers.
So I want to illustrate
this with Waze Carpool.
Waze Carpool launched, I
think in California last year,
and then in Washington
earlier this year.
And it allows drivers
to pair up with riders
and for a nominal compensation
to be exchanged between the two
so that you can carpool
effectively to work,
spend time with
people you enjoy--
so you can set preferences
on who you drive with--
get there faster in the HOV
lane, and reduce commute costs.
So this is what Waze costs
looked like in our reports
dashboard earlier this year.
This is kind of a nice
view, because it also
shows you a general pattern
with what cloud costs usually
look like, which is
compute costs tend
to be the large cost,
and that makes sense.
And there's cyclicality
and periodicity your costs.
It may correspond to
daily cyclicality--
so Waze has that with morning
and evening commutes--
or seasonal cyclicality--
retail periods, other things
like that.
But in general, there's a
longer-term secular trend
of those costs that also
keeps the cloud administrator
confident that their
environment isn't running out
of control, that they
don't have runaway costs.
But just at a
glance, you can see,
something happened
earlier last year
where there was a big spike.
I presume Waze
investigated that,
because that doesn't
look like it was normal.
Maybe a few months ago,
there was a smaller spike--
may or may not have been normal.
And that's worth investigating.
So just at a
glance, Waze can log
in to the cloud console
on GCP and see what's
going on with their service.
And again, a service that serves
over 100 million users, where
they've driven 22 and
1/2 billion kilometers,
is all represented by the
infrastructure on this chart.
So then they launched
Waze Carpool.
And this was the trend after
they launched Waze Carpool.
And so immediately, we've
answered, at a high level,
the three questions.
What's my spending level?
So you have the spending
level at any moment of time.
What's the trend?
And you have this
short-term trend, but also
the long-term trend,
which is more interesting.
One of the questions
I would want
to ask myself
launching a new service
is, is the cost growth good?
Is it growing sublinearly
with customer demand,
is it in control,
or is something
happening where our costs
are spiraling out of control
compared to the
demand we expected?
And this shows a nice story
of what the secular growth was
before they launched
this major new feature
and what it looked like after
the launched the feature.
And you can also
see that nothing big
changed about their makeup,
at least at a glance, here.
Compute costs still seem to
be the same fraction, BigQuery
analysis costs, cloud
storage, and so forth.
So just this visual
understanding of cloud costs
is very powerful, because the
visual explanation is just
a really good way to communicate
the structure of costs.
So I just want to
do one footnote
before we head into how
to track cloud costs,
because there's really
two ways to go about it.
One way is tops-down.
You could use the
resource hierarchy
and put resources in a project.
Everything on Google
Cloud Platform
is assigned to a project.
And you can set up an
organization, folders
under that organization,
projects under each folder,
and then resources
within a project.
And users operate
within projects.
They have permissions to create
resources within projects.
And so if you've created
a nice project hierarchy,
and you've thought
well about it,
you could have a project that
corresponds to an application.
And then all of
the costs in that
project are application costs.
Or you could have a project that
captures all of an environment,
like the dev environment.
So all the costs in that project
would be the dev environment
costs, and so forth.
The other way to track costs
is bottoms-up through labels.
And labels apply to resources.
So you can ask your
developers or set up
tools that automatically
attach labels
to resources that are created.
And then you can get, basically,
matrix allocation of costs.
You might say, OK,
within project A,
I know my costs are x in total.
But I also know that the
environment prod in project A
costs some fraction of x.
Environment dev costs some
other fraction, and so on.
And that's how you
can use labels.
You can also attach
other important metadata,
like who's the owner of the
resource, what's the cost
center, things like that.
So these are two things to think
about as you're-- no matter how
you want to monitor and manage
costs in Google Cloud Platform.
So we're going to focus a lot
of today on billing reports.
But I just want to make
you aware of a couple
of other major features
that might be useful to you
in monitoring and
managing cloud costs.
One is Billing Export.
The other is Budgets and Alerts.
And the last one, which
we'll do an in-depth demo on,
is Billing Reports.
So Billing Export is
really where you would just
dive in, write detailed queries,
and answer customized questions
about your cloud costs.
All of the labels go
into Billing Export.
You see what service was used,
what SKU was use, details
about the project and the SKU.
And over time, we'll be adding
more and more information
to BigQuery Export.
And what's cool
about this is you
can connect to other
tools like Data Studio.
There's another talk we gave
explaining how to do that.
And so this really allows you
to answer fine-grained questions
about cloud costs.
The next feature we
have, Budgets and Alerts,
is really worth
taking a look at.
You can set budgets at the
billing account or project
level and then set
thresholds for when
you want to be notified
about that budget.
And the notification can happen
via email or programmatically
via Pub/Sub.
So email is great for
cloud administrators who
just want to be aware of
things and may not be operating
a large-scale operation.
But Pub/Sub and
programmatic notifications
are especially cool
if you're running
a really large application,
or if you're technically savvy
and can set up really
simple responses
to those notifications, like,
oh, if project A exceeds 90%,
please start
throttling project A.
And that unleashes
very cool solutions
for your organization.
And Matt and Lucas
Carlson from the Broad
give a very cool talk
about that earlier.
It will be on YouTube.
So now, I'll turn
it over to Phill.
And he'll walk you
through Billing Reports.
PHILL COLETTI: So now,
we're going to dive
into the Billing Reports tool
in a little bit more detail.
And we'll do that
through the lens
of our hypothetical
enterprise, Acme Company.
And they want to answer
the same questions
as most other IT organizations.
What are my costs?
What are my cost trends?
And what are my cost drivers?
But before we actually
look at the tool
in too much great detail,
a quick show of hands--
who here has used Google Cloud
Billing Reports in the Cloud
Console?
Looks like maybe 30%.
OK, so for some of you, you
may have already seen this tool
and used it.
For others of you, it may be
familiar, given some other BI
tools that you've used.
And for many of us, this
may be first time seeing it.
So we'll learn something.
Could we cut back over
to the demo, please?
Fantastic.
First, let's just take a
quick look at the tool.
I'll give a quick walkthrough.
And then we can look at
answering those questions.
So for starters,
we can get to this
by going to the Billing tab
and the Reports section.
Right at the top,
here, of the page,
we have a summary bar, which
includes high-level information
about what our costs
are for our app.
Below that, we have a chart that
lets us analyze trends and see
how our usage breaks down.
And then at the
bottom, we have a table
that summarizes and rolls up
the information from that chart.
Lastly, on the right
section of the page,
we have grouping
and filter controls
that let us slice and dice
our data and filter down
to the scope of spend that's
relevant for us to look at.
OK, so to answer
those questions,
first, what are our costs?
The summary bar gives us a
really nice, concise answer
to that.
So far, in the first 26
days of July, for our demo
here, we've spent $1,400.
For the entire month
of July, looking
at the right half
of the summary bar,
we can see that we're forecasted
to spend about $1,800.
So we can see easily
that the summary bar--
it gives us a really
nice, quick answer
that we can answer that
question in maybe 5 seconds.
Next, what are our cost trends?
In the first 26 days
of July, it looks
like our costs are
down about 3.5%
over the preceding
26-day period.
But for the entire
month of July,
it looks like we're
forecasted to spend about 8.5%
more than we did in
the month of June.
This is because we're
growing, also because July
has one more day than June.
So we would expect costs to
go up a little bit anyways.
But to look at these
trends in more detail,
I'm going to look
down at the chart.
A few things here to note-- one,
we have a stacked line chart.
So the total height
of the stacked line
is what we're spending
on a daily level.
But each one of these segments
represents a meaningful portion
of our spend.
Here, we're grouping by project.
So each one of these
colored segments
represents the spend
for a single project.
At Acme Company, we organize
our applications into projects.
So each one of these
colored segments
is how much we're spending on
one application for one day.
Lastly, we have a
dotted gray line here
that represents our cost trend.
And this is how we get
to this forecasted cost
number for the month.
The forecasted cost is the sum
of our actual spend to date
and our forecasted spend for
the remainder of the month.
But to look at it--
I want to explain a little bit
how we get to this cost trend
number.
It's a feature we've
rolled out recently.
And it's pretty powerful.
So I'm going to select the
custom date range here,
just so that we can get
a little more context.
I'll look at the period
from May 1 to August 25.
OK, so for the
purposes of the demo,
we created this account
sometime in mid-May.
And the account grew along
with our hypothetical demand.
And the cost trend picks up on
that long-term, secular, stable
trend.
And it projects it out up to
about a month into the future.
So the way this
works is, we take
the entire history for
the billing account,
all the spend that
you've had to date,
and we look for the most
recent stable long-term trend.
So maybe, if you launched a new
application, like Waze Carpool,
it would start at that point.
Or if you went through a major
cost optimization effort,
it might start after that.
It also does a good job
of ignoring spikes like we
see here in the middle of June.
So it really just picks up on
whatever your organic growth
trend is and will forecast
that forward into the future.
Great.
So now, we have a quick answer
of our first two questions,
what are my costs and
what are my cost trends?
But we've answered this only
for the entire billing account.
What if we want to
know a little bit more
about a single
application-- in this case,
let's say Phill's
Amazing Application,
not to toot my
own horn too much.
We can answer the same
questions just by filtering down
to that one project.
We can see that so
far, we've spent $450
on the application this month.
We're expected to spend about
$600 in the month of July.
And that represents about a 36%
growth over the month of June.
OK.
So lastly, the one
question we haven't really
dove into too much yet is,
what are my cost drivers?
So to do that, I want to
go back to those spikes
that we saw in June.
I've selected the
previous month here,
so we can look at those
in a bit more detail.
So here, we see a
spike around June 8.
And we see another
spike around June 11.
And I want to know,
at a high level, what
changed to cause those spikes?
The chart's a really
powerful tool for doing this.
And we can quickly see, just
by hovering over this section,
that this orange slice, which
was our Good Enough Project,
that really changed a lot.
It grew at that time.
And it also grew for
the June 11 spike.
On that June 11
spike, we also see
that we had some growth in
this blue segment, which was
Phill's Amazing Application.
But I can get a
little more detail.
I want to understand what
changed in those applications
to cause those spikes.
And let's look at Good
Enough Project first.
So I'll filter down
to just that project.
And then I want to
ask the question,
which products or
services changed
to cause the cost to increase?
So I'll group by product
instead of by project.
And now, I can see that
BigQuery, all of a sudden,
went from nothing
to $28 overnight.
And that may have
been unexpected.
It may have been
something we planned for.
We can get even a
little more detail
and see what happened in
BigQuery by filtering down
to just that
product and grouping
by SKU to see if there
are any trends in the SKUs
that we were using.
So not surprisingly, it's
analysis, not storage,
that fluctuated really highly
up and then came back down.
And at this point, this
is about as much detail
as we can get from this report.
But we might want to go talk
to, say, our data science team
and learn what kinds of
queries they were running.
And if they were
pulling a data set
to build a new predictive model
that we get a lot of value out
of, that may be totally fine.
If, however, we
want to trade off
some of the flexibility
for a little more
predictable and
controllable costs,
we might want to
look into something
like flat-rate BigQuery pricing.
OK.
So now, I want to go
through a similar process
and try to understand what
happened in Phill's Amazing
Application in the
middle of June.
So again, I'm going to filter
down to just Phill's Amazing
Application.
And we can see, just by
hovering over the chart,
we were spending about $8 a day.
And then it jumped up to about
$35 a day sometime in mid-June.
And that's something I'd want
to know-- say, what products,
what services changed.
So again, I'll filter down
to just Compute Engine--
sorry, jumped ahead.
I would group by product.
And I would see what
products changed.
In this case, we can see, in
Phill's Amazing Application,
we run two products or
services, both App Engine
and Compute Engine.
And Compute Engine is
where the change occurred.
And again, we can get
a little more detail
by looking at what our
changes were in our SKUs.
So here, I'll just filter down
to Compute Engine and group
by SKU.
And there's a couple
of changes that we
can see here during that spike.
Normally, just by
hovering over, I can see,
we run n1-standard-1s, which is
our smallest standard machine
type of the n1 family.
But then, right here in
the middle of the month,
we see a couple other
flavors of SKU--
n1-standard-8s and
n1-standard-16s,
which are bigger and more
expensive than what we normally
run.
And again, this is
about as much detail
as you can get from
a high-level report.
But you might want to dive
into more detailed data
in, like, your Stackdriver
logs or in our BigQuery Billing
Export.
Or we might go talk to the
project owner or the engineer
and say, hey, is there a reason
why we're running these bigger
machines, and why
we didn't spin them
down for a few days afterwards?
Additionally, when
we see something
like that, if it's
unexpected, we
may want to set up a
passive monitoring solution,
like Budgets and
Alerts, so that we're
notified if our spend trends
quicker than we expect.
At this point, we can cut
back over to the slides.
So now, we've gone through
a demo of Billing Reports.
We've seen how we can use this
tool to really quickly get
a high-level answer to our three
key cost management questions.
And we've also
seen how we can get
to a certain level of
depth, at which point
we need to go to either a
more detailed data source,
like our Billing Export,
or like Stackdriver
logs, to get even more rich
detail about, say, machine
utilization.
Or we can go talk to
the relevant teams
to figure out what happened
when we see spikes,
like we did in the
middle of June.
So that concludes our demo.
Before we wrap up, I
just want to highlight
a couple of other
sessions related
to cost management and billing.
On Tuesday, we had a
talk by James Byers
on how to organize and structure
your resources, which also
relates to the
slide that Stephen
went through earlier about
labels versus projects
and folders.
We also had a pretty cool talk
yesterday with Dale and Dale
from Vendasta, where they did
some interesting live demos
about how to use BigQuery
Export and Data Studio to slice
and dice your data.
And lastly, Matt
and Lucas Carlson
talked a bit about how
we can control our cloud
costs with financial
governance tools.
We also have a
showcase downstairs,
on the bottom floor
of Moscone West.
Please stop by and say hi.
We'll be there, probably
after this presentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]